oceans 8 is directed by Gary Ross and
star Sandra Bullock Cate Blanchett and
Hathaway and tons of talent and is about
Debbie ocean the sister of Danny ocean
formerly played by George Clooney and a
heist that herself and a crew are trying
to pull off at the New York City met
gala before I go any further with the
review I want to make sure you guys stay
tuned for the end of the video when I
talk about Skillshare which is a
fantastic learning platform for
filmmakers writers editors animators a
lot of really great stuff on there so
stay tuned so oceans 8 is in fact a
sequel to the original trilogy that was
helmed by Steven Soderbergh the first
being a remake of the 1960s film with
Frank Sinatra and I've said this before
but I'll say it again ocean's 11 and
John Carpenter's The Thing those are my
two favorite remakes I think that
Soderbergh did a fantastic job with that
original film and the sequels weren't as
good but they were at least watchable
the third one was better than the second
so I was happy to learn that this film
was not a reboot or a remake of the
original and it's actually a sequel
taking place within that world that
being said the film feels pretty much
like a reboot or remake of the
Soderbergh film in almost every single
way the opening scene is Sandra Bullock
at her parole meeting and the cameras
based on her and you just hear the
voices of the parole officers in the
background and they ask her what she
would do if she was released just like
in Soda Berg's original film and I was
disappointed to see that this film
follows a beat for beat formula of the
first film in every way it is the first
movie just with a different cast it
never tries to be its own thing they
basically took the blueprint that was
set up in soda Berg's film changed the
caste gender and instead of money it's
jewels now I don't want to say that that
means this film is bad I certainly am
NOT saying that I'm just noticing the
comparisons and the fact that it is so
drastically obvious that they were
basically pacing around an office when
they were writing this script and
comparing what the first one did beat
for beat and trying to recreate that
which is disappointing that being said
this film is very breezy and super
watchable the cast is phenomenal
everyone works well with one another
Sandra Bullock as usual is extremely
charming she's always been fantastic as
is Cate Blanchett I would say I was most
concerned about Rihanna being in the
film because she is the one that seems
to have the least experience out of this
extremely a list cast and she was fine
you know her her role as a hacker who
doesn't really like to talk that much
kind of is perfect and she didn't bother
me in the movie no one really did
everyone is good it's a beautiful
looking movie something I specifically
noticed was all of the wardrobe choices
their dresses the outfits they wear even
when they're planning the the heist it
they all have like these really amazing
outfits and that's not usually something
I pay attention to and that means that
it was really good it's shot well but
nowhere near as well as what sort of a
good with his trilogy this movie feels
like it's trying to be a Soderbergh film
which I guess makes sense if you view it
from the lens of Gary Ross tried to make
a film that fits within a franchise and
so we understand the feel and you can
watch them all back-to-back and it feels
like it fits but it also feels like
someone who is aping Soderbergh style
it's not like a blatant thing but
there's a lot of zooms and a lot of
wides that last for a very long time
just like Soderbergh and so it's not
like Soderbergh necessarily owns that
but it just couldn't escape the fact
that it didn't feel like it was its own
film it's always weird when I see a film
like this because aesthetically it's
fine everyone's good it looks good
they're charismatic and charming and
they all have good chemistry
the music is jazzy and upbeat it feels
like a fun caper movie but it also feels
like a fun caper movie that we've seen
three times already and not as good as
those time well it's probably better
than Ocean's Twelve
I think to make a film like this better
you have to make it not so easy to
compare it to the others because that's
gonna do it a disservice you know when
you make a sequel especially a fourth
film and a franchise you want it to feel
like it's kind of its own thing if
you're going to do such a big cast
change like this and barely have any of
the original crew involved you have to
kind of make it feel like it's its own
thing or it has some vitality of its own
and beyond the fact that the cast is
different it doesn't just about
everything in the movie is exactly like
the others and so it's going to draw
those
Harrisons and it's not as good as the
original it doesn't have as good of a
villain as Andy Garcia not even close or
s Pacino in Ocean's thirteen and so the
heist doesn't really have that much
intensity to it either it's just people
walking around smirking wearing amazing
dresses and awesome clothes with great
jazz music and a lot of really expensive
looking stuff and there's a list stars
walking in and out of frame having
cameos that and you're like oh there's
that part okay there's that oh they're
all in the movie I guess and I guess
that's just supposed to blind us to the
fact that the script doesn't really have
anything new to say or do I feel like
this film could have been so much better
if they found a way to make it its own
thing and if they can't then just don't
make it at all but I gotta say I could
watch the film like it was enjoyable
there's never a moment as I said where I
was like I hate this movie I hate being
here I don't want to watch the rest of
the film it's not hard to watch a movie
with Sandra Bullock Cate Blanchett and
Hathaway and all these amazing stars
it's really not hard it makes it easy
because you have so much talent on
screen and everything looks pretty nice
it's just that there's really not that
much there and it's tough to really
justify why the film exists and I try to
look at that whenever I see a sequel is
this just a reboot or remake to make
more money on this franchise name well
kind of this is one of those movies that
reminds me why I don't always like
grades high grade movies because I
always have and people enjoy like that
summary of your thoughts but a film like
this
I'm very split on because I had no
problem watching it but under the
surface there's just so many things
about it that bothered me because it
basically is just a remake I'm gonna
give o scenes eight a C+ if you guys do
decide to see ocean's 8 this weekend let
me know what you thought of it I'm
curious to hear other people's thoughts
thank you so much as always for watching
I also want to say thank you so much to
the sponsor for this video and that is
Skillshare Skillshare is a learning
platform and online community with
thousands of classes but in particular
and what interests me is their classes
on filmmaking editing animation and
writing they have a very helpful course
on doing your
of cinematography and DSLR filmmaking
for beginners classes on how to vlog
film edit and upload to YouTube as far
as learning platforms go Skillshare is
definitely more affordable than most
their annual subscription is less than
ten dollars a month but if you're one of
the first 500 people who go to the link
in the description below if you'd like
to learn more about skill share and what
you can learn there you can sign up and
the first 500 people get their first two
months free so guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]
you